hello everybody and welcome to my first
video recorded specifically for YouTube
my name is Grandmaster Daniel neared its
key and in this and the next video I'd
like to examine two games that I played
against none other than the current
world chess champion grandmaster Magnus
Carlsen now these were not games played
over the board but rather games played
in the September 2019 titled arena held
on the website li chess org where we
will analyze these games titled arena is
a monthly event that is held for title
players only so players who have title
of candidate master or above and if they
feature a time control of one minute per
player so it's called bullet chess and
bullet chess is just as scintillating
it's kind of the fastest form of real
chess it's only one minute per player
and the great thing about the titled
arenas only chess is that they generally
feature the participation of Magnus
Carlsen who's sort of the star of the
show and I generally play in these
titled arenas and throughout the months
I've had the honor and privilege of
facing the world champion many times in
in our bullet battles and in September
2019 and that titled arena I actually
beat Magnus Carlsen six times and lost
only one game now truth be told I got
very lucky in most of these games but so
in this video I'd like to examine the
most fascinating of our seven encounters
in the 2000 September 2019 titled arena
the first thing that might be going
through your mind is well why look at a
bullet game I mean what's that good for
and my answer to that question is that
even though we both had one minute on
our clocks to start the game the battle
that we had was very very fascinating
very instructive and I hope that you
guys enjoyed so without further ado
let's jump in in this game I have the
black pieces and Magnus has the white
pieces Magna starts the game off with
the move teeth
I respond with Knight f6 in Magnus plays
an opening that's frequently called the
Jew Baba London and starts with the move
Knight c3 is those of you who are quite
seasons might know c4 is considered to
be the main move here in the black as a
bunch of different openings I was
playing in the Kings Indian defense with
g6 there's also the nimzo-indian defense
with east six but no matter Magnus plays
Knight c3 the idea of this move is to
prepare to occupy the center with e4 so
logically I respond to the move d5 which
of course brings the e4 square under
control there is a move in this position
Bishop g5 which is called the veresov
it's an old line that's not considered
very good but Magnus plays the line that
I actually quite like it's a play with
the white pieces which is which is this
move Bishop f4 why develops his bishop
onto an active square and essentially
why it's not playing for the move c4 in
this position why it's probably going to
orient himself around eventually
preparing the move e to e4 he can't do
that immediately but that's sort of a
very hyper modern line that's gained a
lot in popularity I respond to the move
c5 so the reason behind this move is
that since white cannot play the move c2
to c3 defending the pawn I decide to
immediately contest white Center and
basically force Magnus to put his cards
on the table and so Magnus responds with
e3 reinforcing the pawn on c4 aye aye
cap sure Magnus captures and this is an
important early moments the tempting
move here would be to simply develop a
knight with with the move knight c6 but
this is actually a grave error and it's
one of the reasons this line is so
appealing for white white has the move
Knight b5 and there's actually basically
no way to stop the fork on c7 without
giving up significant material black has
to make the very awkward move e5 but
after Bishop takes e5 White has a pawn
to the good and he's got a huge
initiative so this move knight c6 would
have been in this position would have
been a huge blunder which is why I play
the move a6 bringing the b5 square under
control Magnus plays Bishop d3 now I
develop my night with knight c6 Magnus
plays the move Knight c2e2 defending the
pawn on g4 his other Knight will go to F
3 which is a move that I try to stop
with this move Bishop chief
now if Magnus develops would Knight f3
this would be it would be a grave
positional error because I'm able to
[ __ ] his pawn structure permanently
with the capture on f3 and now I play e6
and these pawns are obviously very very
bad he's never gonna be able to cap to
Castle kingside and have his king safe
so for that reason Magnus chases away my
Bishop h3 I play Bishop h5 the bishop
stays on the diag and only here Magnus
makes a very flexible move c3 he
reinforces the pawn on g4 he kind of
waits for me to to show my cards and so
I play the move Bishop g6 which one
could consider to be a slight inaccuracy
because the whole point of Bishop g4 was
to was to stop his knight from
developing to f3 now I kind of
voluntarily moved my bishop away but do
you remember this is a bullet game so
you know these sorts of subtleties are
let's just say not too relevant this
isn't too bad of a move east 6 would
have been a better idea basically
keeping the f3 square under control and
the position would probably be around
equal here so after Bishop g6 Magnus
seizes the opportunity he develops with
Knight f3 I play e6 castles Bishop d6
nothing to write home about here we're
just developing our pieces the fun stuff
begins a little bit later so Magnus
plays rook e1 sort of occupying a
semi-open file with his rook I Castle
short here he plays kind of an annoying
move Bishop g5 pinning the Knights of
the Queen which dictates my response
Bishop e7 I don't want to deal with you
know the pin on the knight I really want
to be able to play move like 94 now
obviously I can't do that here the Queen
is pin as we mentioned so I'm sort of
preparing to occupy this very nice
outpost for my knight Magnus plays
Knight f4 basically forcing my hands
takes the bishop Knight takes D 3 and
here i oq PI this very very juicy
central square and that's kind of what
you want to do once you complete your
development you want to take pieces that
are not situated perfectly and then
place them on very active squares that's
one of the main middle game strategies
in chess and this is no exception so
Magnus captures on e7 I capture back
with the Knights and Magnus makes a very
logical move 92 he identifies my
strongest piece which is in the knight
on e4
he tries to trade it and I say no way
Jose I played above 96 now you might be
thinking well that's a win for white
right because my night was very active
maybe I should have made a move like
that five guarding the night and
reinforcing with both of my pawns but
this would have actually been a very
grave error due to f3 White chases away
the night anyway and after Knight takes
t2 Queen takes t2 you might notice that
this pawn on e6 is dreadfully weak and
it can be attacked by white in a variety
of ways for example Knight c5 or a
knight of 4 and then white might double
on the e-file and reinforce the pressure
on this pawn so I certainly didn't want
to do that this 996 you know remains
relevance I can still put it on you for
at some point and I will actually see
that this night will play a very very
big role in the unfolding of the
situation so Magnus plays the move out
for which is a little bit strange he
sees his space on the Kings side but he
weakens the e4 square permanently so now
this line on d2 one can say is tied down
to the defense of that Square as soon as
this Knight moves my knight can jump
back into e4 so this is a slight mistake
Magnus should have made a neutral move
like a four maybe ceasing space on the
Queen side so after a for this night on
e7 is a little bit passive so I decide
to activate it with the move Knight f5
Magnus plays Queen f3 developing as
Queen and now I play Queen h4 activating
my own queen and then seizing control
over this juicy little square on g3
which is exactly what Magnus tries to
remedy with his next move King age 2
basically preparing potentially to chase
away my queen of the move g3 he doesn't
want to deal with a headache of of the
night having access to that square so I
preemptively go Queen h6 I also don't
want to deal with a headache of having
to move my queen after g3 and notice
that this Queen also can test the f4
pawn now am I gonna capture this pawn
not necessarily but it's important to
kind of keep the tension in order to tie
down your opponent's pieces so Magnus
chases away the night he loses his
patience he plays g4 and this is where
stuff gets really fun this is where
we're really gonna go into the details
of the game
now you might notice he does chase away
the night but look at his king you might
have heard the principal
don't move pawns in front of the King
and Magnus I assure you is familiar with
that principle but what he's trying to
do here is Bank on the fact that my
pieces are very passive so he is
essentially reasoning that my pieces
will not be able to exploit the weakness
of his King which is why he can kind of
get away with a move g4 and he's
absolutely right this move is according
to the engine quite strong the mistake
that he makes actually comes a little
bit later Knight relocates to h4 which I
perceived to be a pretty active square
Queen chief 3 and now I made it at what
I think is a very strong move f5 on the
surface this might seem like a mistake
and I think that's where Magnus kind of
went wrong because not only does it
weaken the pawn on e6 because as we
discussed earlier that was that was a
big mistake back on you know move 15 but
also it creates this huge weakness on
the e5 square so I'm basically creating
all these positional weaknesses what am
i gaining by doing this and the answer
is that again I'm looking at his King
this pawn enough five threatens to
capture on g4 let's say he makes a
neutral move like a 4 which which he
didn't now what happens is that if I
ever capture on g4 he can't capture back
with his pawn because I have this very
very strong discovered Czech winning a
huge amount of material either the rook
on e1 or let's say the knight on g2 and
I'm a piece up so this pawn on f5
actually acts as a kind of battering ram
destroying the position of his King and
in reality he plays g5 introducing
further weaknesses in his position he
keeps pushing his pawns down the board
but there's a lot of squares he's
leaving behind which is what I try to
exploit with the move Queen h5 and this
is where stuff gets really really
interesting the correct move in this
position would have been something very
calm for example Queen e3 relocating the
Queen to a good square attacking the
pawn on on e6 I would have responded
with 94 Magnus could have responded and
turned here with 95 in the positions
very double-edged I would say the
position is about equal I like black
here but according to the computer it's
still within the realm of equality but
Magnus having looked at this position
remember again this is a bullock game in
a bullock game you frequently do the
first thing
to mine and here Magnus snaps the Ponte
six it looks like he's about to emerge
superior he's up upon he's attacking the
knight but this rook which looks very
very strong is about to become one of
white's greatest liabilities and here I
slam the knight on to e4 revealing
another idea of the move f5 which is
that I created for my knight that's very
very strong outpost on e4 now Magnus is
compelled to take my knight he just
doesn't have any other moves he can't
move his Queen here I just take the
Queen he can't move his Queen here
notice I take the knight he takes back
now notice the position of the king of
the Queen therefore Keable and you know
as luck would have it I have a knight
that can deliver that fork and I win the
Queen so he has to take my night and he
eliminated this you know demonic 994 but
in place of that Knight comes another
very very strong pawn this move
accomplishes two things first of all I'm
attacking the knight this pawn is very
strong but also it opens up the F file
for my rook those of you with a lot of
experience in chess you might see that
storm clouds have begun to gather around
White's King I mean I have a knight I
have a queen Queens and Knights are a
very very strong tandem especially when
they're attacking as we're about to see
this rook will also play a very
important role Magnus has no choice but
to go forward you know as the Russian
expression goes having said a you also
have to say be so madness you know full
steam ahead is nine and a rook on e6 95
but again he's exposed his King in this
hidden way which I now exploit with the
move Queen e2 check penetrating to eat
you giving a check he can't block the
check both squares are defended so
Magnus plays kim jiwon and i think this
is probably the most important point of
the whole game it might appear the black
doesn't have a good way to follow up
because the knight is under attack and
if we move tonight let's say back white
moves his queen back and white says big
deal what do you have to show for it
because I don't want to trade Queens
that gives me an endgame and remember
White's up a pawn and a retreating move
like Queen h5 after king h2 white is
perfectly safe here
all of black's pieces have been driven
back so a piece of advice that I always
share with my students is you have
to sense the moments when there might be
some sort of a strike and in those
moments you have to take more time so
what I noticed here is that have a
knight on h4 of a queen on e2 this
square on g2 is a potential checkmating
square
however the square is guarded by White's
Queen
but that already sets a potential
tactical precedent because this Queen on
g3 in chess we call it the Queen is
overloaded the Queen is guarding this
potential checkmating score but it's
also guarding this f4 pawn and so I slam
the move rook say well I don't
physically slam it it's an online game
but you know I symbol eclis slam the
move rook takes f4 down on the board
this is a classic overloading tactic he
can't take my rook because of Queen [ __ ]
you checked me you can't take my night
the knight is defended by the rook so
now the rook comes into the game the F
file is open I have three huge pieces in
the attack and Magnus's rook and Knight
aren't fulfilling the same role but this
is where Magnus shows that he is in fact
Magnuson he uncorks a beautiful move
it's the only move that keeps him in the
game look to f6 now I would encourage
you to maybe even pause the video take a
moment to let this move sink in he's
putting his rook literally on pre the
rook can be captured by the pawn which
is in fact what happens but let's talk
for a second about his idea his idea is
that he's gonna recapture the pawn
that's a discovered check all of a
sudden this Queen on g3 which looked
completely innocuous is now playing an
attacking role and if blacks King runs
to f8 the King is gonna get checkmate it
in two moves that's pretty obvious now
if I capture this this dastardly rook
with my own rook and he's gonna take
with a pawn and all of a sudden with the
rook gone the life has gone out of
blacks attack and I have to take
emergency measures with Knight f5 and
this is this is not not what I want I
have to trade Queens here and the
endgame is gonna be very unclear so in
this moment I took I think five to five
or ten let's actually see I took I took
a whole six seconds and I had 29 seconds
at this point so six seconds out of 29
that's a huge chunk of my time at this
point Magnus had 26 seconds
but I forced myself to calculate and I
didn't trust him I knew this was Magnus
this move looks intimidating but I asked
myself a very important question after G
takes f6 she takes f6 can I cover this
check I can't cover it with a rook
that's just absurd but I can cover it
with the Knights after 96 this move
looks disastrous because Magnus captures
on g6 and if I take we already know the
mating pattern bike white takes why
doesn't even need the night to give
checkmate whoops that's not the correct
move this is gonna be checkmate so the
question then becomes what is bike to
about it because it seems like a
discovered check is on the cards but in
reality I play the move rook f3 here and
at this point I have 21 seconds and
after 97 check which actually looks
quite devastating King up 7 it turns out
the blacks King is able to escape and
this is it's very important even in a
bullock game not to trust appearances it
might appear that blacks king is gonna
get checkmated but in fact I have this
really nice escape chute to e6 that is
exactly where the King runs Queen g7
track King e6
Queen g4 check King continues to run
Knight a5 check King continues to run 97
check I repeated the position once I had
16 seconds at this point but a draw was
not on my mind and unfortunately this
was the only point in the game where I
made a very serious mistake what I saw
was that the King has this really nice
square and a7 and I directed my king
there with king b6 we'll talk about why
this is a mistake in a second the
correct move would have been king c7 and
after Knight takes d5 check the king
goes forward to d6 this is a common
technique kind of circumventing the
Knights chucks White is completely out
of checks and the game is basically over
if white plays a move like metaphor the
simplest is to simply pick off the
Knights and black and choose between
trade and Queen sear or or basically
just delivering checkmate so this would
have finished the game immediately
instead I played king b6 and Magnus in
return blundered with a very natural new
Knight takes d5 but he had 11 seconds at
this point this allowed my king to run
to a7 and complete the escape but I
encourage you here to pause the video
and actually try to find what I missed
your Magnus had a beautiful drawing
combination
and the combination begins on the move
Queenie six check which I saw I thought
I just play King a seven big deal
but here white sacrifices this night
with my c6 check and the idea is to open
up the position of blacks King and after
Queen e7 it's actually perpetual check
which means to check the black cannot
escape from King b6 Queen c5 check it
doesn't matter where the King goes
wherever he goes the Queen has an
equivalent check that sends the King
back where it came from this would have
been actually a draw so you can see this
happens very commonly in Bullitt where
you just don't have time to calculate
but fortunately Magnus took you made the
tempting move now the King has escaped
and now it is my turn to checkmate
White's King and Magnus plays King h1
out of desperation I play the move h5
distracting the Queen from the defense
of the h3 Square had Magnus taken on h5
I was planning the simple move rook f1
check that's another discovered check
but it doesn't discover the king and
discovers the Queen simply take the
Queen the game is over but the computer
also indicates the simple rook g8
basically leads to check me notice that
blacks king is still perfectly safe in
the game Magnus played Queen g3 I
responded with rook f3 attacking the
Queen I repeated the move repeated moves
once now I play h4 which is the simplest
win further distracting the Queen from
the h2 square Magnus plays queen g4 it
doesn't matter where he would have gone
had he taken the pawn then this is
checkmate had he gone Queen e5 them this
is checkmate
Magnus plays queen g4 rook h2 check and
here we both had 7 seconds on the clock
and Magnus resigns because after King h1
this is checkmate so that was actually
my first win in this tournaments in this
titled arena against Magnus it felt very
good now notice that the critical moment
the game proceeded along very kind of
tame fashion and so Magnus took on e6
and I think his real mistake was to play
this move g4 and then maybe to play this
move chief v he really sent his pawns
down the board weakened himself and then
I was able to play this move rook takes
f4 which really decided the outcome of
the game followed by sober calculation
even in a bullet game 96 I should also
point out if
gives me a pawn Shack here that doesn't
do anything after King g7 amazingly why
does no follow-up here so after that I
was able to calculate that my King in
fact escapes I made this small blunder
but fortunately was not punished Magnus
with 12 seconds on the clock you know
even Magnus is not able to find
everything and after Knight takes d5 the
King became safe and is able to turn my
attention to White's King so that was my
first win against Magnus I hope you guys
enjoyed this little analysis session I
apologize for any mistakes or any
anything that I said that was wrong this
is after all my first video recorded
specifically for YouTube and in the next
video we'll take a look at my other
interesting victory over Magnus in the
September 2019 titled arena I hope you
folks enjoyed the video
you're more than welcome to leave
comments down below I will try to
respond to any pertinent questions about
the game and if you enjoy this content
be sure to tune in to my twitch stream
at twitch.tv slash GM nee Radetzky I
will also link it in the description
down below I stream quite regularly so
you're welcome to tune in for speed
chess analysis and fun conversation hope
you folks enjoyed thank you very much
for listening and I will see you guys in
the next video thank you very much